今天大家定了一個題目
就是「洪水重臨」
不知道這個題目會讓你想起什麼呢?
不知道你會不會想起
幾年前《國家地理》雜誌
曾經有一部紀錄片
英文叫做 Before the Flood
中文譯作《洪水來臨前》
同樣是在談論、關注氣候變化
今天並不是電影欣賞會
但這部紀錄片其實在 YouTube 上就找得到
今天定這個題目其實很合適
為什麼呢?因為你知道,兩三個禮拜前
在英國有一場氣候高峰會
我想大家都沒有去到現場示威
最近曾經有一項調查
顯示有四分之三的年輕人
對於將來充滿了恐懼
原因就是氣候變化
很多年輕人
對前景充滿迷茫,因為前路似乎並不確定
洪水來臨
我記得在2009年的時候,曾經有一則新聞
印度洋島國馬爾代夫
內閣開會,特地走到海底
就是帶著潛水裝備,在海底舉行這場內閣會議
為什麼呢?
他們想引起全球的關注、國際的關注
如果不理會氣候的變化,這裡海水不斷升高
那麼他們的國家就會沉到海底
而這裡則是所羅門群島
位於太平洋、南太平洋的所羅門群島
這是一個《60分鐘》時事雜誌節目
節目訪問了當地的一個人
最上面這幅圖
看見的就是
這個人
小時候
就
經常到這裡玩
但是現在
這個島已經沒有了
你已經看不到這個島了
海水不斷升高,很多陸地都被淹沒了
另外順帶一提,在你的
右下角這幅圖
也很有意思
因為海水升高
原本那些植物,因為海水是鹹的
那些植物就會死去
這一點
我們待會還會再提到
海水慢慢升高,很多陸地就被淹沒了
你會發覺不只是島國
這裡就是意大利的威尼斯
因為海水上升
近年經常都
出現水浸
不知道你有沒有聽過「摩西計劃」
他們計劃建造一些水閘,用來擋住海水
這就是2019年時水浸的情況
後面那座橋很有名
如果你去過威尼斯人酒店
外面也有一座這樣的橋,對吧
這裡本來是一條河
但是海水浸上來,已經浸到
商舖、行人路了,你看到那些船就停在這裡
而且不只是2019年,2020年又再水浸
也就是說,近年很多時候都會水浸
大家在紐西蘭,不知道你有沒有留意這則新聞:在你上方有一個國家就是印尼,印尼的首都就是雅加達,最近也宣布要遷都,為什麼呢?
因為雅加達位於海邊,由於海水高漲,經常水浸,每次一下雨、一颳風就水浸;原因是當地很多人抽取地下水,導致雅加達陸地下陷、不斷下降,再加上海水又升高,每年都浸得很嚴重,所以決定遷去加里曼丹島。
其實這影響著很多國家、很多人
比如在孟加拉
沿岸很多人都已經搬去
較北、較內陸的地方
這些就是
氣候難民
因為海水不斷升高
不只是海水升高
這個畫面,如果你留意新聞就會明白
今年7月中國河南
因為連場豪雨
你看到這樣的景象:隧道被淹,傷亡都很嚴重。
左下方這幅圖,就是當日被淹的地下鐵路,
地下鐵路車廂裡,水浸到人的上半身。
為什麼會下這麼大的雨,浸得這麼嚴重呢?
因為由於氣候變暖,空氣暖了,
空氣裡能夠容納的水分就多了,
所以使得這些 Torrential Rain,也就是驟雨
下起來的時候非常嚴重
幾個鐘頭就可能下了幾天的雨量
幾天就可能下了一年的雨量
認得這裡是哪裡嗎?
認不出來吧
這裡同樣是7月
不過是在紐西蘭
下雨了,經過一個週末之後
雨下完之後的景況
所以不只是中國
也不只是北半球
南半球都一樣
幾天前
留意新聞就知道,溫哥華下雨下得很嚴重
令溫哥華與周邊對外的交通中斷
因為很多公路被淹
很多橋
都被沖斷了
你看到右邊
就是火車軌
鐵路
也被沖壞了
你會發覺,不只是驟雨會造成這些後果
近年如果你留意,每一次颳風你都會聽到所謂的「風暴潮」
風暴潮的意思就是:由於颳風的時候
風眼的地方就是低氣壓
會把海水抬高
所以每次颳風,潮水就會升高
這個就叫風暴潮
這就是2005年時,在美國
海水升高,吹襲紐奧良之後的景況
所以不在乎你的
城市是怎樣
就像美國這樣
你會發覺一樣會水浸
剛才我提過
海水升高會使沿岸的植物死去
其實後來有人研究,為什麼 Katrina 會令紐奧良有這麼嚴重的水浸
當然一方面是 Katrina 本身
風力比較強
另外有些堤壩決堤了
但也有一個很重要的原因,就是因為
海水不斷升高
使得沿岸很多沼澤地方的植物都死了
以致沿岸就
沒有了一個緩衝地帶,沒有了一個 buffer zone
所以颳風的時候
那些風、那些海浪
就直接衝擊市區
這就是
2005年 Katrina 的情況
這就是2012年的 Hurricane Sandy
不知道你認不認得這是哪裡,這裡是紐約
在美國東岸
值得一提,紐約其實位於北緯40多度
Hurricane 的意思就是巨風
如果在香港,就叫做 Typhoon
其實它正式的學名叫 Tropical Cyclone
也就是熱帶氣旋
顧名思義,這些風全都在熱帶地方發生
紐約在北緯四十幾度
你可以看見,如今全球暖化令很多熱帶災害
例如颳風颳到很北的地方,似乎已成為一種新常態
同樣地,如果你去過紐約,就會知道那裡的地形
海水升高、風暴潮
使得曼哈頓被淹,也就是 Lower Manhattan(下曼哈頓)
你知道其實紐約有一個別名叫做
City that Never Sleeps,也就是不夜城
基本上下曼哈頓是一個金融中心
24小時都燈火通明
因為那些
金融交易
原來很多金融機構的電腦就在地底
那一次的水浸
損失很嚴重
其實之後用了好幾年時間才慢慢恢復
同樣也淹了這些地下鐵
很多老鼠都跑了出來
彷彿幫城市清洗了一番
你右邊這幅圖
你很難想像,平時人來人往的地鐵站竟然水浸
你看見那些潛水人員在搜救
這是2017年澳門颱風「天鴿」吹襲
由於這場風暴潮,海水倒灌
使得市區變成這樣
這一次的傷亡也很嚴重
其實香港的照片我沒有放出來
你會發覺每一年
一颳風
近年2017年有「天鴿」、2018年有「山竹」
你會發覺沿岸的地方,無論是將軍澳
還是杏花邨等一些較低窪的地方
沿岸就經常被海浪侵襲
說到這裡
我想起一節聖經,在路加福音21章
聖經裡講到將來主回來之前世界的景況
其中有這樣一句話
地上的邦國也有困苦
因海中波浪的響聲,就慌慌不定
聖經也提到我們末後的日子
其中一個災害,彷彿就是海中的波浪
剛才我們看過這海水的升高,也就是風暴潮;其實我最初留意到這一節聖經,是在2004年
就是因為南亞海嘯
當然還有後來2011年東日本大地震引發的海嘯
這些彷彿都在告訴我們
這一種情況——因著海中的波浪
人就慌慌不定
說到這裡,我想起聖經裡特別記載了一件事
主耶穌在世上的時候,曾經在加利利海幫助門徒
當時突然遇上大風浪,門徒中有一些本是漁夫,也見過風浪
但因為風浪太大,他們甚至覺得沒命了
但主卻在船尾睡著了;他們叫醒主,說主啊,我們沒命了
主起身之後,就斥責風浪,使風浪平靜了
我覺得聖經裡記載的這件事很有意思
一方面,你看見主耶穌
他真是能夠搭救我們脫離危險
另一方面也說明,主能夠平靜風浪
無論在你人生中
遇到什麼艱難
打擊,有什麼風浪
主都能夠平靜一切風浪
如果今天有基督徒朋友邀請你來
其實基督徒朋友都很樂意跟你分享,主是如何幫助他平靜人生中的風浪
好,考考大家一個問題
在這杯水裡裝滿了冰,也裝滿了水,水已經到了杯口
隔一段時間之後,當冰融化,問大家一個問題:到底水會不會流出杯外呢?
不會。
不會啊?真厲害。
其實我想說什麼呢?水是很特別的東西,不只是它的結構,因為 H₂O,H 就是 Hydrogen(氫),你知道它本身可以燃燒;O 就是 Oxygen,也就是氧氣,本身能夠助燃。
但竟然
氫氣加上氧氣變成水,就能夠救火
另外還有一樣特別:所有東西都是熱脹冷縮
當溫度越低的時候,水的體積就越縮小
但很奇怪
當到了攝氏4度的時候
體積
就縮到最小
就不再縮小了
到了3度、2度、1度,到0度結冰的時候,體積就開始膨脹
所以密度反而會降低
因為密度低了,所以你會發覺冰浮在水面上
所以會發覺冰是很特別的
為什麼呢?我覺得這是神的憐憫
你想想,如果水變成冰的時候,密度變高、沉到水底
那麼海裡所有的生物就都死了
你想像一下,就等於人走到懸崖邊,一跌下去就死了
但你會發覺很奇妙,當水結冰的時候,體積反而會膨脹,密度會降低,以致浮在水面上。
還有一樣東西很特別,就是什麼呢?你看到冰是不是很大?
但是當冰變回水的時候,它的體積反而會縮小;因為剛才說過,結冰的時候體積變大,變回水的時候體積就會縮小。
而它縮小的那部分體積,正好就是它突出水面的那個 volume(體積)
所以有些人說,你見到冰山就快點離開
其實你看到冰山突出水面的部分大約只有11%左右
在水面下有89%
所以有九成的冰山是在水面以下的
所以你遠遠看到冰山的時候
其實水底下的冰可能已經很接近你,也說不定
原來浮在海洋上、浮在水面上的冰,並不會令海水升高,只會令北極熊找不到落腳的地方;因為冰融化了,可能要去很遠的地方才找得到落腳點。
也就是說,真正令海水升高的
其實最主要的是陸地上的冰
通常人們說的就是什麼呢
就是格陵蘭和南極洲
這裡有一則新聞
就在今年8月
你會覺得很特別
就是格陵蘭第一次下雨
我起初也不以為然
我當時有一個感覺,就是什麼呢
難道格陵蘭以前沒有下過雨?
你覺得為什麼這會出現在頭條裡呢?
其實你想一想,格陵蘭在加拿大東邊、很北的地方
其實它不該下雨,它應該下雪,你明白嗎?
所以格陵蘭第一次記錄到下雨,就反映出溫度升高了
而在你的右邊,你看見那些狗拉著雪橇
牠們並不是在水面上走,而是因為那些冰的表層
表層融化得很厲害
所以你這樣拍下去
就好像那些狗
在水面上行走
其實這就是在 Greenland
也就是格陵蘭
表面的冰融化的情況
有人計算過,如果格陵蘭的冰融化
海水大約會升高二十多英尺,大約兩層樓
兩層樓
都有二十多英尺,已經很高了;不知道大家住的地方離海邊近不近
不知道大家
住在幾樓
但如果南極的水、南極的冰融化,又會怎樣呢?
南極的冰是格陵蘭的九倍
也就是說,如果南極的冰和格陵蘭的冰一起融化的話
全世界海水的高度就會升高到21、22層樓左右
你們想聽聽那個情景嗎?
這還只是由於陸地上的冰融化而令海水升高
其實當溫度升高的時候,還有一個因素、還有一個影響是很大的
就是因為溫度高,海水膨脹
海水膨脹而令海面升高,這個情況其實很嚴重
今年2月有一則新聞
就是俄羅斯首次有破冰船能夠橫越
北冰洋以前一些無法通過的航道
這說明了什麼呢
這就說明北冰洋、北極
那些冰薄了很多
可能你會說
別急,你剛剛才說完
你說北極
在海上的冰融化是不會影響海水高度的
但是呢
還有其他的影響
近年你有沒有經常聽到「熱浪」?
今年6月就經歷過了
今年6月,熱浪曾侵襲加拿大,而加拿大很北
溫哥華是北緯50度的地方
但想想溫哥華
隔壁的卡爾加里
卡爾加里
攝氏40幾度
可能你會覺得很奇怪
為什麼這麼北會有熱浪呢?如果你留意一下近年的熱浪
經常都是由於一種情況,所謂的 Heat Dome
中文俗稱「熱蓋」
一個覆蓋的「蓋」
想像一下,你煮東西、煮水
有蓋跟沒蓋
是不是不同?
蓋上蓋是不是很快就滾了?
因為那些蒸氣散不掉
蒸氣散不出去
很快就滾了
情況也是一樣
因為這幅圖你看見
你看不看得見這裡有一道 jet stream
也就是高空的高速氣流
它形成了一個高氣壓
就使得下面那些空氣
雖然它並不熱
但卻散不掉
沒辦法散去
就好像蓋上了蓋一樣
就使得在很短的時間裡
那些空氣
就加熱得很快
所以你想想,到了北緯50幾度
竟然也能錄得攝氏40幾度
其實這是很誇張的
好
不過我想請你留意
我並不是想介紹那個 Heat Dome
也順帶多介紹一個詞
其實這樣一種氣流的現象
叫做 Omega Block
因為它的形狀很像希臘文 Omega 這個字母
其實我想請你留意高空氣流 jet stream 的影響
你會發覺,因為它的擺動
使得熱空氣散不掉,就出現了 Heat Dome、Heat Wave(熱浪)
同樣地,由於這樣的擺動
你看見,它使得北極裡的寒流
那些極地的漩渦就往南
有些地方就延伸得更南
所以近年你經常聽到很多新聞,就是
有很多地方出現熱浪
同時
又有很多地方
出現破紀錄的低溫
甚至曾經有一次
有一次
多倫多
陸地的溫度比北極還要低
為什麼呢
就是因為這樣的現象
可能你會問一個問題
為什麼這 jet stream 會這樣擺動呢
其實這 jet stream 擺動的原因
就是因為它變弱了
因為它變弱了、因為它減慢了
你想像一下,就好像一條河
去到下游的地方、去到平原的地方
它的速度是不是慢了?因為沒那麼陡斜
為了往前走,它是不是就會擺動
那條河是不是就會擺動,meandering(蜿蜒)
其實是同樣的情況
因為 jet stream
它變弱了、減慢了
就使它擺動;因為這樣的擺動
使得剛才我說的那些熱浪,或者那些北極寒流的侵襲,變得更加頻繁
好,那你會問一個問題:為什麼會變弱了呢?
其實這就證明了一件事,就是北極暖了很多
因為原來北極的溫度和周圍溫度的相差
如果相差越大,因為周圍流入北極的空氣速度就快,jet stream 就強
而當北極溫度升高之後,溫差變小,就使這 jet stream 變弱了。
其實有研究顯示,全球的溫度變化並不一致,而在北極,溫度的升高是周圍地方的4倍。
也就是說,北極地方是暖得更快的。
可能你會問一個問題,就是為什麼會暖得這麼快呢?
其中一個很主要的原因是西伯利亞大火
其實這場火已經燒了好幾年;其實21世紀最大的一場火
就是今年在西伯利亞、在俄羅斯燒起的大火
其實這個火場的面積,比起北美洲
加州、加拿大加起來的山火
再加上歐洲、加上土耳其的山火,面積還要大
這是從高空拍攝到的
西伯利亞火警的情況,你會發覺是不是很多地方都沒有煙?
為什麼這麼奇怪?為什麼我看不到火,只看到煙?
原來在西伯利亞、在北極圈裡的火是很特別的
這種火有個名字叫做 Zombie fire,也就是喪屍火,顧名思義,知道是什麼意思嗎?
既蓋不住它,又撲滅不了它
為什麼會這樣?因為北極圈裡低溫
很多植物死了之後
沒有分解
所以泥土下面有很多有機物質
而當發生火警的時候,有時這些火
就會燒到地底
燒到地底的時候
你會發覺就
你沒辦法撲滅
但有機會又會燒上來
燒到地面
所以這場火其實燒了好幾年
有沒有影響呢
這就是在衛星圖片上拍到的地面情況
你看見是不是很多火頭
其實地底下面是在燒著的
但一有機會就冒出地面
漫山遍野都在冒煙,就是這樣的情況
你說西伯利亞大火
北極圈大火有什麼影響呢
去年有這樣一則新聞
你看見上面那幅圖,那條河是不是被染紅了
不是因為流血
而是因為
漏油
你知道北極圈的地
叫做 Permafrost(永久凍土),也就是那些積了很多冰、已經結冰的凍土
上面有很多煉油設施、有很多油庫
但是隨著北極圈的溫度升高,這些冰融化
使得很多煉油設施、譬如油庫下陷,就漏油
這就是去年5月的時候漏油的情況,是一場生態災難
如果你去西伯利亞,近年經常都會看到這些坑
你看見這些人,就能體會這些坑有多大
為什麼會有這麼大的坑呢?
誰有那麼多時間去挖坑呢?其實這並不是挖出來的
而是因為凍土暖了、冰融化
就釋放出困在地裡的甲烷
而甲烷
這個你看見
好像有一個 bubble(氣泡)一樣
也就是在泥土下面
在那些植被下面
有一些甲烷氣體
有時它就會發生爆炸
就造成了剛才你看到的那些坑
而在這些水面下的那些 bubble
全都是 methane(甲烷)
如果你在網上找到一些照片
就有一些人在那裡玩
就在那些冰上
鑿一個洞,然後點火
其實這甲烷
作為一種溫室氣體
其實 methane 的影響比二氧化碳還要高20倍
也就是說,同樣體積的二氧化碳對溫度的影響
如果換成甲烷,它的影響是20倍
所以有人這樣研究過了
他說什麼呢?
他說,一旦西伯利亞的甲烷釋放出來
那個影響就相當於全球二氧化碳排放總和的影響
這是很大的危機
另外我想起聖經裡
另外一句話
在啟示錄裡講到將來災難的日子裡
天使將碗倒在太陽上
太陽就能夠用火烤人
現在有時有些地方都熱到40幾度了,剛才講過溫哥華
Calgary(卡爾加里)
另外有些地方甚至熱到50幾度
剛才如果我講到那些 methane 這樣釋放出來
其實對於全球的溫度
影響可以變得很快
變得很急促
所以如果你問我
你說太陽烤人
我覺得這並不是
什麼天方夜譚
其實現在已經有跡象讓我們看見
全球的暖化
其實可以
變得很快
變得很惡劣
在這幅圖裡讓我們看見
山林大火的情況
剛才我們說過西伯利亞的大火
你看到了
這裡你也看到有幾場火
這一場就是亞馬遜森林
這裡就是非洲剛果盆地
這裡就是印尼婆羅洲
都是熱帶地方
都是一些 tropical rainforest
熱帶雨林區
都燒得很嚴重
西伯利亞的火剛才我們說過了
那亞馬遜森林又怎樣呢
其實亞馬遜森林的火,很多是人為放的
有些是砍伐樹木,我們取用木材
更多的是燒掉樹林之後用來養牛
為什麼會這樣呢?
因為牛的 market price,也就是牛的價值高
能夠賣到多一些錢
所以你會發覺,氣候峰會裡其中一個主題
就是提供一些資助給一些國家
譬如巴西這樣的國家
好讓它禁止人們去砍伐亞馬遜森林
但其實
我不知道現在會不會已經有點為時已晚
為什麼呢
近年有很多研究
顯示亞馬遜森林是全球最大的
熱帶雨林區
可以說是地球的第一個肺
但是呢
有些研究顯示
亞馬遜森林的碳排放
現在已經超過它的碳吸收
一般來說
一個雨林區,當有陽光的時候,有光合作用,它就會吸入大氣層裡的二氧化碳,轉化成樹木裡的碳,這就是所謂的碳吸收。
但是為什麼碳排放更多呢?一方面,當它著火之後,是不是釋放出很多二氧化碳?另外還排出很多碳的微粒。
其實近幾年的趨勢,亞馬遜森林的碳排放已經超過碳吸收了
其實我想起,這些日子是不是經常都有冠狀病毒?它引起的問題就是肺炎
肺炎就是呼吸不了,似乎地球也患了肺炎
另外還有就是剛才我講過的這個非洲剛果盆地
這個可以說是全世界第二個肺
也是一個熱帶雨林區
在你的右邊看到兩幅照片
你可以看到,其實那些救火設施是很落後的
大火怎麼救呢?
就是靠那些東西噴一下噴一下
好像水槍那樣,怎麼救呢?
但那些火是怎麼來的呢?
其實那些火是人刻意放的
因為在非洲地方
如果要得到糧食就要耕種
那怎麼耕種呢
他們會用一種方法,叫「火耕」
也就是說,燒掉一片樹林
這樣就有了一個範圍
那些枯葉還可以像肥料一樣幫助耕作
然後就在那裡種植
而如果種了幾年之後
那個地方就會因為長出很多雜草
於是那些人就會搬到別處,再燒另一個地方
而原先那個地方
就讓它
慢慢恢復,重新長出植物
其實以前一直都是這樣運作的
這種火耕的運作方式
叫做「刀耕火種」
為什麼現在一發不可收拾呢
其實這就引申出一個問題
因為人多了
因為人口多了
那些棄置的地方沒有時間
沒有足夠的時間讓它恢復
因為多了人要吃東西
所以他們只能燒
就沒有時間讓那些樹林恢復
就使得全球的第二個肺也引發了肺炎
這就是第二個問題
就是近這一百年裡
全世界的人口急速增長
從這幅圖裡看見
在1930年全世界有20億人
但是到了今年,已經是11月底了
全球的人口已經有79億了
根據推算,雖然有疫情
但可能到了明年年底
全世界的人口就會突破、超過80億
也就是說,由20億
到80億
其實前後還不到100年
這是一個很嚴重的問題
因為當人口多的時候
地球的資源是有限的
哪些地方的人口增長得特別厲害呢
就是非洲
所以也有人估計
幾年之後
全世界最大的城市不是紐約,不是東京,而是在尼日利亞的一個地方,叫做拉各斯(Lagos)。
非洲是人口增長得很快的地方,另外就是中東地區。
另外當然還有印度;中國13億人,其實老化得很快。
所以近年放寬了一孩政策,鼓勵生育,甚至催促人們生兩三個孩子
當人口多的時候,有些事是沒辦法的
所以你會發覺,氣候峰會竟然沒有觸及這個問題
反而只是倚靠碳排放國家;碳排放最大的國家就是中國,第二是印度
兩個都是人口過十億的國家
但你知道,這些承諾都只是口頭上的
為什麼呢?因為譬如上個月
你看見中國是不是在東北出現電荒
又到過冬時,又沒有電了
也不知道那些暖氣要怎麼來、怎麼弄
而在中國,發電很多時候是燒煤的
人口多,又鬧電荒
更不用說那些生產都需要電力了
而發電主要是燒煤
那它怎麼能夠承諾減排呢
所以其實
這是一個很大的問題;而旁邊右邊這幅圖
就有很多人關注所謂地球的 carrying capacity(承載力)
也就是說,到底地球
它的面積、它的資源能夠支持多少人呢
近幾十年很多人研究
多數科學家有一個共識,就是什麼呢?就是全球的
資源能夠供應80億人
但別忘記,由於各樣的天災、氣候的變化
旱災我們今天還沒有提
其實你可以想像,地球是一個平衡
有些地方雨下得那麼嚴重的時候
你也應該想像得到,有些地方是非常嚴重的乾旱
加州就是一個例子
這些災害同時也會降低地球的 carrying capacity
所以其實這是一個都不知道該怎麼解決的問題
所以說到這裡,我就想起這艘船,這艘 Titanic;Titanic 沉沒就是因為它撞上冰山。話說當年,當它撞上冰山的時候,船長立刻召開會議,因為那位設計師也在船上,船主也在,大家就聚在一起,
他們檢視之後,發覺船頭的地方,第一個、第二個、第三個、第四個、第五個 compartment,也就是船艙都進水了
那位設計師就很緊張
因為這艘船是他設計的
船長就問
進水能不能用泵把水抽走呢
大家你看我、我看你,就已經知道發生什麼事了
用泵抽水只能夠 buy time(爭取時間)
幾分鐘而已
為什麼呢
因為這艘船
三個艙、四個艙漏水,還可以浮在水上,
但如果五個艙,就沒辦法浮起來了。
那船主就問了,
船主說,怎麼可能呢?
這是處女航、第一次啊。
那位設計師就說,
這艘船是鋼鐵造的,
它會沉。
It's just a mathematical certainty,
也就是說,這是一個數學上的必然。
其實當你看見剛才這樣的情況
是很艱難的。
我想起幾年前,戈爾在卸任美國副總統之後,關注全球氣候變化
拍了一部片,叫做 An Inconvenient Truth
中文香港譯作什麼?《絕望真相》
我覺得說到這裡,真的沒有希望
也許你會說,全球攜手,減少碳排放
其實剛才也提過,起碼它忽略了一個很大的問題
就是人口的問題
再說,各國輪流攜手減排也是一個問題
所以為什麼七成的年輕人
對於前面沒有什麼盼望
充滿了恐懼
想到這裡,我覺得
如果真的沒有盼望
我真的不知道該跟大家分享什麼好
但是很寶貴
原來聖經最後給我們留下這樣一句話
就是主耶穌說的
主耶穌他差遣他的使者
向教會證明什麼呢?
下面有一句話,他說什麼?
他說:我就是明亮的晨星
原來當天越夜的時候就越黑、越冷
當到了最冷的時候,臨近天亮的時候
晨星就出現了
當人看見晨星的時候,就知道很快就要天亮了
主的意思是什麼呢?
他就是要給人盼望
當看見他的時候
天亮的時候就快到了
為什麼呢?
因為主耶穌已經應許過,要為我們預備地方
當我們預備好地方之後,他要回來,把一切信的人接到他那裡去
所以這個世界的景況
其實是要預備人的心
讓人知道
沒有盼望
但是很寶貴
有主耶穌的人
他有一個活潑的盼望,就是主耶穌要回來
把我們接到他那裡去
接著我會和大家分享一首詩歌
這首歌叫做《主如明亮的晨星》
帶給我們盼望、帶給我們光亮
使我們在絕望中仍然能夠看見遠處的出路